hello there we're approaching five years
of fortnite battle royale over that time
we've seen some inventive ways to play
some ways are more devious than others
so today we're counting down the 15
greatest meme strats in fortnite history
to be on the list the meme strat must
give us easy eliminations or easy wins
be sure to use code adamaru to support
me and let me know which memes you've
tried in the comments below
number 15 let's start with chapter 3.
season 3's reality tree gave us seed to
plant to grow our very own weapons we
could even steal them from other
people's saplings the mean strat this
season is to jump into the plant's
blooming leaves and sit completely still
waiting for an unsuspecting player to
walk by then
to really perfect this mean strat
players would use skins which blended in
perfectly i mean look at this it's tough
to spot the ambusher nope i can't resist
one of the most iconic meme strats back
in 2018 was all about c4 we loved that
stuff we put it on golf carts we put it
in trolleys we put it anywhere epic
would let us then chapter 2 arrived and
we could hide in boxes and yeah c4 stuck
nicely to the sides the meme was simple
one player was boxed and covered in
explosives and then sent to get as close
as they could to the opposition usually
using a launch pad then on their call
the c4 was detonated and the strat was
complete did you ever try it were you
the one getting the elims or the guy in
the box that night
number 13. another one from chapter 2
was the most simple meme tactic ever
conceived the waterfall floor swimming
was added this chapter and the rivers
became essential to rotating into the
zone and diving from the waterfall
without looking was a daily event for
most of us and then this happened the
worst thing about this was while falling
from the waterfall you know you had been
had it hurt your pride to be eliminated
by a waterfall
[Laughter]
it's like i told you fresh it works for
everybody
chapter 2 also brought us the ufos
amazing vehicles with a tractor beam a
terrible meme strat became popular and
it was all about that beam it could lift
objects players and vehicles so what did
we all do we started dropping and
throwing enemies into the storm and
worse still it became a friendly fire
tactic in squads trolling a teammate by
constantly throwing them back into the
storm may be the most toxic thing on
this list
but very memorable too
bye have a great time there we go back
to chapter 3 now and the day we all
rejoiced as spider-man joined the island
spider-man had an unlockable emote that
looks like this harmless right well this
emote could be used to hide in roofs if
timed right it was possible to go
completely unseen or better still pounce
on your enemy and pick up an easy
elimination while they're still trying
to figure out what the heck happened
right there is your first meme strat of
chapter three
up to number ten this is a great meme
strat the invisible trap in chapter one
it was possible to get eliminations by
offering free loot with a trap
underneath it looked like there was a
floor tile to walk on but it actually
wasn't there the setup was simple a trap
a few walls and a rare item to entice
other players the trick was to construct
a floor edit it jump in then edit the
tile back to a floor piece but to
prevent it from fully forming by
overlapping your character's head this
made everything look legit but hell no
this was a literal death trap one of the
greatest meme strats ever created
that was gorgeous number nine remember
the invasion storyline one of the unique
weapons brought in that season was the
chimera ray gun a meme strat rose around
that weapon as it was possible to find
in the one-shot game mode as you know
one shot is a sniper mode all about
accuracy well by going to see farmer
steele and revealing he's an undercover
chimera agent he would drop the ray gun
now it was possible to use in the
one-shot game mode and look how it melts
everyone as long as you didn't get too
cocky three wins were coming your way
number eight chapter two gave us the
greatest meme ideas ever
like the cuttlefish this pink squid
could be used for so many meme strats i
mean they could be hidden in plain sight
underneath loot the best two meme ideas
i saw were hiding them under supply
drops and waiting for someone to come
past to open it they'd be met with this
another was to throw them inside
vehicles smashing the windows then
throwing them on the seats and then when
another player started driving boom
instant classic cuddle fish may be my
favorite thing to happen in fortnite in
2021 yes
yes
yes we're on to the top seven now and we
have to pay homage to the reboot van
meem hiding on top of the reboot van
this strat became synonymous with the
frozen love ranger skin who blended in
so well to the blue glow above the van
memez would first grab a shotty then
sitting waiting at the reboot van ready
to pounce on any unsuspecting players
just trying to reboot their teammates
this tactic is still used today three
years later we can still hide on top of
the reboot fans and i'd say this was
inspiration for the sapling meme from
earlier in the video oh god damn it
number six chapter two gave us the
ability to fish and a slurp factory
which could heal us constantly thanks to
an outlet pipe which fed into the
swampland by teaming up both of these
skills together it was possible to win a
game of fortnite in the storm the strat
was to catch as many fish and pick up as
many white heels as possible then set up
your home base around that waste pipe
from there all you had to do was consume
and eat every time your health got low
and if you were lucky enough you would
get the dog
let's go number five were you playing
fortnite when the zero point floated
high in the sky season five of chapter
two let us jump into the zero point and
refill our health bar players quickly
noticed it was possible to do this over
and over and over again which gave us
the free wind strat we could heal
quicker than the storm could hurt us
doing this for 22 minutes was extremely
boring but if winds are what your team
needed this was the strat free wins all
day okay
let's go
let's go
number four remember when the plastic
patroller was added to the game the toy
soldier design was loved until its meme
potential was unlocked it was possible
to sit near bushes and stones and be
rendered almost invisible a pay to win
skin like no other this became such an
issue that the skins were changed to
look tarnished look at them now they're
repulsive but for a week they were mean
gold
top three time back to chapter one again
and a meme so silly it's perfect back in
2017 large mushrooms existed but these
didn't have collision which meant memers
could literally sit inside them when
teamed up with the right skin those
memers could become almost invisible
because nobody ever checked the
mushrooms so these fun guys could hide
all game picking up e limbs with little
effort this was such an issue that epic
removed the huge mushrooms and the meme
was no more rip mushroom trolls
what's the oldest meme strat you can
think of my guess is the sky bass
chapter one of g's rejoice when fortnite
was the new game on the block and we
were all getting used to building a few
people began to sky base ramping to the
height limit and slowly edging into the
next circle nowadays we all know to look
up in the late game just in case to spot
these guys but back in 2017 it was
possible to win games without any fights
at all we called it a stairway to heaven
back then as players learned about this
tactic it became harder to successfully
complete yet in chapter 3 the
unbreakable sky base was created using
armored flaws preventing the structure
from being shot down the sky base meme
will never end
[Laughter]
and number one okay so my pick for the
greatest meme strat in fortnite history
is all thanks to this skin mystique who
has the ability to shapeshift into
anyone she eliminates this was a great
way to try skins before you bought them
or to wear an og skin you may have
missed but memes took this power and
made a strategy like no other they would
find the latest npc to join the island
and take them out then using mystique's
ability they'd replace them performing
all their actions and you know what
happens when another player came over
they'd attack them hilarious for the
memer but devastating for the unknown
casual now in chapter three i can
finally get my hands on the original
paradigm skin i missed all the way back
in chapter 1. it feels good as for the
meme i don't think it will ever end
shoot now
so that's my list do you agree what did
i miss please let me know in the
comments if we get enough we'll make a
part two i'm adam you're awesome here's
some legends who used my code this time
from my discord thanks for watching i'll
see you next time
[Music]